Rosanne goes on Bill Mars Show and she
makes pretty weighty accusation about
him no wonder I don't remember this no
you blocked it out MK
Ultra who's that that's the mind control
program you're under Bill MK Ultra yeah
so who's but who's CLA Schwab the head
of the
wef what's that Google
it love Roseanne she's great Google it
now people are looking at this clip
saying man Roseanne's crazy isn't she
she's always been a little crazy she
said she's a little crazy most comedians
are here though Roseanne doesn't really
sound like the crazy one to me Ro
Roseanne comes at she says Bill you're
under an MK
Ultra mind control program but the
crazier thing is Bill says he doesn't
know what it is he's never heard of MK
Ultra